if you only just learned his name
because of his star turning Elvis you
might be shocked to know that Austin
Butler has been appearing on screen for
nearly 20 years here's where you may
have seen him before without even
knowing it
Butler was born in Anaheim California in
1991. his mother lorianne was a
beautician and his father David is a
real estate broker though his parents
divorced when he was seven Butler's
upbringing was by all accounts normal if
perhaps a little solitary he told GQ I
didn't really have a passion for
anything that included other people at
that time I wouldn't go play sports I
wouldn't do things with other kids
though he attended Elementary School in
Orange County he was homeschooled as a
preschooler he told the Orange County
Register in 2016. I have vivid memories
of my mom saying instead of doing school
work let's just go to Disneyland I have
such happy memories of that place
Butler's Big Break would come at a
different place of amusement though when
he was 12 Butler was visiting the Orange
County Fair with his stepbrother when
they were approached by a representative
for a background acting management
company Butler says the Scout was
initially interested in his stepbrother
who had a mop of unruly hair and a more
distinctive look Butler told the
register they said to my mom you have
another son have him audition as well
well tagging along to the audition
turned out to be a stroke of incredible
luck Butler soon was cast as a
background character on the Nickelodeon
sitcom Ned's Declassified School
Survival Guide and from there he went on
to appear in more than 40 episodes as
Zippy Brewster a James K Polk Middle
School student and frequent classmate of
the title character
Butler appeared on the second and third
seasons of Ned's Declassified School
Survival Guide while he was on the show
he was once again homeschooled and took
acting classes eventually testing out of
high school at age 15. his co-star
Lindsay Shaw put him in touch with her
manager Pat Cutler who began to
represent Butler as well in 2007 he
appeared on an episode of Nickelodeon's
iCarly as Jake the cutest boy in school
but oh my God he's so hot I want to make
cookies on him
I'd eat those cookies
that same year he made the leap to the
Disney Channel appearing on two episodes
of Hannah Montana with his biggest role
as a cute but frightened young man then
in 2008 he landed a recurring role in
season four of Zoe 101 on Nickelodeon as
you guessed it the cutest boy in school
sensing a trap and playing all these
heartthrob roles Butler sharpened his
Ambitions and pined for more serious
work telling GQ I wanted to do a part
like What's Eating Gilbert Grape or The
Basketball Diaries I was watching Raging
Bull and those types of films and going
I don't want to be the guy who walks in
slo-mo through a door
Butler might have been done with cute
guy roles but they weren't quite done
with him in 2009 he booked his first
feature film 20th Century Fox sci-fi
family adventure Aliens in the Attic
part home invasion Thriller part
kid-friendly Creature Feature the film
stars Carter Jenkins and Ashley Tisdale
as a Teenage brother and sister who
discovered that their Michigan vacation
home has been infiltrated by diminutive
extraterrestrials with the power to
control the minds of grown-ups Butler
co-stars as the siblings Meathead cousin
who gets roped into saving the world and
while he manages some decent physical
comedy bits the film wasn't particularly
well received Butler would play yet
another dimwitted cousin that same year
and the short-lived ABC Family sitcom
Ruby and the rockets starring former spy
kid Alexa Vega as Ruby and 1970s
heartthrob David Cassidy as her
estranged has been rock star dead the
show attempted to be a whole bunch of
things at once it was a father-daughter
reconciliation story and a behind the
music parody as well as a found family
comedy Ruby meets the cousins she never
knew she had including some out of place
humor involving Butler as her horned dog
relative ultimately the show fell back
on the type of Dopey humor that wouldn't
have been out of place in the juvenile
Nick shows from which Butler had just
graduated
in the early 2010s Butler continued to
book a succession of television roles
that didn't Veer too far from the Teen
heartthrobs he had played on Nickelodeon
though he did display an early aptitude
for mimicry breaking out a pretty good
Matthew McConaughey impersonation on a
2010 episode of the Jonas Brothers
Disney Channel series Jonas well I've
got a web Empire usually describe my
message it's all about Easy Living
saving the ocean if you want to be cool
about my stuff in between guest
appearances on the Wizards of Waverly
Place and the High School Musical
spin-off Sharpay's Fabulous Adventure he
got to pop up in more adult-oriented
shows like two of the CSI series and are
you there Chelsea Butler was also a
regular on the teen drama's Life
Unexpected and Switched at Birth in 2013
he booked His Highest profile gig yet as
Sebastian Kidd the on and off again
boyfriend of a young Carrie Bradshaw in
the CW's sex into the city prequel The
Carrie Diaries the series starred Anna
Sophia robbes Kerry narrating her High
School Misadventures just as her adult
counterpart would Chronicle earlier New
York City while the part was yet another
hunk role for Butler he did his best to
OK through the poor little rich boy
characterization
the mid to late 2010s saw Butler's film
career pick up co-starring with former
iCarly star Miranda Cosgrove in the 2015
Indie haunted house Thriller The
Intruders he also appeared in films from
two Indie icon directors Jim jarmish's
zombie satire the dead don't die and
Kevin Smith's yoga hosers neither role
would turn out to be life-changing but a
Eugene O'Neill Broadway Revival starring
Denzel Washington that's a different
story in 2018 Butler was cast as a
member of the massive Ensemble of the
Iceman Cometh O'Neill's epic 1946 play
of drunks and Desperation directed by
George C wolf and starring Washington
David Morse Tammy Blanchard and many
more Veterans of stage and Screen Butler
told GQ that his plan to not get
intimidated by Washington was
essentially to outwork him memorizing
the entire script always showing up to
rehearsal before him and so on
eventually Washington took notice and
mentored Butler during the production
Butler said he'd start telling me
thoughts about the scene and suddenly
I've got Denzel almost as an acting
coach that production earned mixed
reviews but Butler Drew attention
theater critic Hilton house review in
the New Yorker called him out for an
exceptional performance
while Butler was in the Iceman Cometh in
New York he was asked to submit an
audition tape to Quentin Tarantino for
his upcoming film when he was 12 Butler
kept a printed copy of the Pulp Fiction
screenplay that he would recite to his
mother while she drove so he jumped at
the chance to work with one of his
Heroes Tarantino asked him to do a live
audition so Butler flew to Los Angeles
on his day off spent the day
workshopping with the acclaimed director
and returned to New York within 24 hours
having landed the role the film was once
upon a time in Hollywood which does some
revisionist history on the murder of
Sharon Tate at the hands of the Manson
family Butler was cast as Charles Tex
Watson one of the many real-life figures
portrayed in the film a follower of
Manson in the film Watson and his
accomplices make an unplanned stop at
the home of Tate's next door neighbor
Rick Dalton and are confronted by Dalton
and his former stuntman and Driver Cliff
Booth when asked on the red carpet how
he coped with playing such a dark figure
Butler told variety that the Monstrous
nature of the role was tempered by the
dream come true of working with
Tarantino as well as Stars Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio
in July 2019 Butler was named as the
star of director baz luhrmann's biopic
of Elvis in that same red carpet
interview at the premiere of Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood Butler's hair was
already dyed jet black and swooped up
with crease and his voice was already
bearing a very elvis-like timber in a
rarity for actors playing the king
Butler would be performing the music
himself for longtime fans however this
was no surprise he had been playing
guitar and singing as far back as iCarly
and Ruby in the Rockets when asked how
he was preparing to play one of the most
recognizable pop culture figures of all
time Butler simply replied many many
hours of hard work
Butler delved into every facet of the
life and influences of the king and
found a tragic personal connection both
Butler and Presley lost their mother at
age 23. production on the film stretched
on for nearly two years due to delays
caused by the covid-19 pandemic when
filming finally wrapped in March 2021
Butler's body gave out the very next day
it was about a week
but Butler's work was well worth the
effort even Chris who don't much like
lerman's maximalist style found the
actor's performance to be a truly
mesmerizing Act of impersonation
while poised at the edge of stardom
Butler is a working actor at heart as
evidenced by those many years in the
teen show trenches so even though he has
some big roles Butler already has his
next gigs lined up he will star in the
Apple TV plus series masters of the air
and the latest World War II drama
produced by Butler's Elvis co-star Tom
Hanks and Steven Spielberg among others
based on the book of the same name by
Donald L Miller the series depicts the
Valiant efforts of the U.S 8th Air Force
division fighting the war in Europe from
above the series caps off an unofficial
Trilogy of Hank's Spielberg World War II
Chronicles that began with 2001's Band
of Brothers and continued with 2010's
the Pacific Butler will also step into
the role once played by Rockstar Sting
the villainous harkinen Warrior fade
rautha in the second installment of
denievel nuv's Blockbuster adaptation of
Frank Herbert's Dune
[Music]